if you and a partner stay together for
between five and eight really seems to
be a sweet spot and a child hasn't come
into this world people can find
themselves falling out of love with
their partner for kind of no real reason
and they don't really know where it
comes from the cute way that she used to
sip her coffee on the morning actually
drives you up the wall or the fact that
he always leaves the forks out on the
dining room table which he used to think
was a little bit okay now it's turning
you inside out there is an evolutionary
program that says if you're in a
committed relationship with a partner
that you're invested in children should
arrive at some point if children don't
arrive there is an incompatibility
somewhere between us two it might be me
it might be you so people that have been
in relationships that have said I found
the love of my life at 21 years old but
we're gonna Hang Fire until we're 29 and
then we'll decide to do it and they get
to 27 and they find I thought that this
was the one and it's actually not that
is a psychological bias which everybody
needs to learn about